The phrase all lives matter was derived
from black lives matter to subvert black
lives matter. And I won't come here
and sit down and say that that's okay.
And I have, I law enforcement
go to the left pool of life,
had my black lives matter orders
go to the right pool of light.
I regularly fear for my life.
Hmm.
You know, I'm an army
patrol officer, so I do.
We were responsive burglar alarms though.
If someone breaks into someone's house,
have a gun, I would have to
respond to that certain situation.
So I do fear for my life in a way,
I guess you can say I do something
that I think every black man,
every black person in this country, many
people of color have been trained to do.
And that's when the law enforcement
officer gets behind me and I'm driving.
I'm making sure I'm signaling,
I'm checking my speed.
I'm thinking of all the different
legitimate ways that you could stop me.
And in that moment I recognized and I
realize that I'm not a scholar with a
bachelor's in political science,
a bachelor's in sociology,
a master's in public policy.
In that moment,
I'm just another black man to
that officer and that scares me.
I,
I've maybe could have stepped forward.
I feel scared for my
life when I'm at work.
Often when you get pulled over and all
the thoughts and things that are going
through your mind. Well,
where when I pull a car over,
I'm thinking about where
I'm at on the highway,
how I'm going to pull this vehicle over.
Did I run the plate?
Did it come back to that vehicle?
Am I buckled in?
Might not buckled in because most officers
are shot and killed during traffic
stops.
And as I approached,
I put my hand on that car to leave my
hand print because if I'm shot and killed,
that person is further incriminated by
the evidence of my prints being on their
car.
But I don't feel afraid for my life as
a citizen that at work I definitely do.
And that's
the choice I made. I, I choose
not to live in fear. Uh,
if the question was do I feel less
safe now than I did five years ago,
I would say yes.
And I think that that's because we have
rampant social chaos that's expanding.
And I think that that's playing a large
role in a lot of the trends that we're
seeing. What do you mean by social
chaos? Um, out of wedlock birth rates,
uh, statistically, you know,
that sets a trial back five times more
likely to be poor in nine times more
likely to drop out of school and 20
times more likely to end up in prison.
I mean,
the cast that I'm seeing more recently
is white men walking into schools with ar
fifteens and slaughtering people.
Yeah.
And then w and then that is what you're
seeing and what you're not seeing is the
dozens of homicides that occur in
Chicago on a daily basis. And that
speaks to,
um,
certainly a media that's desirous to push
an agenda and a narrative that factual,
he knows a bear out there is a massive
disparity between black crime and white
crime and large.
And obviously that's going to lead
to accelerated interactions with law
enforcement. This specific, the
criminalization of black people.
When you have more police officers
patrolling a concentrated area,
then of course you have more
stops. You have more, you know,
situations where police officers say,
oh,
they didn't signal and then when I pulled
them over I pulled all occupants out
of the car.
I searched the car,
I found this gun allegedly
buried somewhere and all
of a sudden now you have a
crime as a public defender.
The the reputation is that you know,
I'm going to lose most of my cases.
I have one far more
cases than I have lost.
My name is Elissa Blair.
I am African American.
I'm also a criminal defense attorney.
As a public defender,
I've seen the mistreatment of my clients.
I see the disproportionate incarceration
of black and brown people and I see the
excessive force used in arrests.
Police should be given more resources.
I think police should definitely be given
more resources so that they have other
options besides killing people.
Officers should have the resources
available to them to handle a situation
without casualty on either side.
Yeah, I mean, as an officer I,
I appreciate hearing that from a member
of the public and from a public defender
and can speak to it for myself and my
department and what I've seen in other
departments in the area and know that we
need more resources and different types
of training,
communication techniques to deescalate
situations and different types of least
force option techniques.
But as a small woman,
I also want to be able to
physically protect myself and it's,
it's a hard balance.
The largest expense for almost every
municipality and county is public safety.
There's plenty of money, but we don't
have is enough implicit bias training.
The things that we carry about ourselves
that define how we interpret who we're
interacting with,
our judgment.
We don't have enough contextualizing
of the communities that you're serving.
Draw officers from the
communities from which they serve.
That way when they go back and they
are policing their own community,
that's deeper than just
the race of the officer.
So you think that black police officers
need to be trained to be more sensitive
to the black communities?
That what you're saying? No,
I think black officers that are policing
black community should come from those
communities.
And I think a white officer who comes
from that community might even be more
effective than a black
officer from somewhere else.
I agree. And I think, I think that this is
a great point, which is that an officer,
a white officer, a black officer, a
female officer, a Hispanic officer,
could be just as good
as any other or better.
And that's because there are
things other than skin color.
And I think that what's so concerning
amount this dialogue is that it is pushing
us further back into black communities,
white communities.
When really I thought that the
goal of Martin Luther King,
what does that we're going to be moving
to a society where we were being judged
by the content of our character.
If we keep moving further into
identifying based on our groups,
I think that we're doing a
disservice to his message,
which I think was very powerful.
And that United the country in many ways,
but not at the time in Martin Luther
King's time. White folks hated him.
It causes me to Bristle.
And and have an emotional reaction
whenever somebody says, you know,
black people are killing folks 50% and
violent crimes and then says Martin
Luther King United the country,
Martin Luther King would be
down for black lives matter
the next day.
It is,
I believe that all lives matter.
It's a little bit surprising
below all of this stuff,
below skin deeper than all of this,
there is a intrinsic God given life
that's put inside of all of us.
I think that it's concerning that any
movement would reject the fundamental
premise of that while preaching for
quality. Exactly. At that point,
and you're really not in a
quality movement if you're
really only interested in
speaking to your specific group.
I truly believe in,
I agree with everything that you say.
Everyone deserves life and I believe
that, you know, life is a gift.
Plain and simple, all life
counts. It's all life matters.
All life deserves a chance.
No.
Yeah.
I think that especially in this platform
but also in the world and the country
that we live in today,
stating that all lives mattered,
takes away from the inequality
that's happening in the world.
Of course all lives matter.
It negates the fact that something has
to be addressed and if you don't address
it and you don't recognize that there
is a problem that has to be changed,
then you never fucking change it.
That's not our intention.
Our intention was just to answer
a simple question, but it's not.
Not Everything is the same and
not everything is the same.
You all lives matter. If you asked
me if all lives have intrinsic value,
if all lives are valuable,
if all lives are worthy,
I would have said hell yes it would
have been the first one in my chair.
All lives matter is a specific phrase
similar to blue lives matter and anything
else that mattered after black lives
were exclaimed to have mattered to the
track,
to appropriate,
to subvert the message in the framing
and the narrative that's being brought to
us by the black lives matter movement.
So I don't think anybody here in this
room thinks that any life is less worthy
than another's.
But the phrase all lives matter was
derived from black lives matter to subvert
black lives matter. And I won't come here
and sit down and say that. That's okay.
I mean I feel like we're just
kind of going into the weeds here.
Question was in the black lives
matter is a simple question.
Do you believe that all lives matter?
I don't think that that's an
interesting phrase. A phrase.
I think that you frequently,
I think not really.
I think that you can attach
it right after. That's what
I try and step back from,
you know, whatever sort of identity,
political stuff we have going on.
And I try and deal with things
head on based on reality.
And when someone says to meet,
do you think all lives matter?
I answer unequivocably yes.
Every time. The same way.
If you asked me a black lives
matter or female lives matter,
I will answer the same way you do.
Black lives matter. Yes they do.
I had conflicting feelings
about coming here today.
Yeah.
For me,
I was conflicted because I,
I don't feel like I should
speak for black oppression,
but as a white woman,
um,
I think that I can be a value to other
white people who may not understand.
I'm Sandra crews and well,
I'm from the 60s and I went to jail a lot
for fighting for women's rights and as
a human being,
I think it's important that I speak
out and speak up for injustices.
I'm feeling conflicted now as someone who
steps into the law enforcement side as
if we are on opposite sides.
Um,
I am a law enforcement officer and
a black lives matter supporter.
I find myself searching for what
to do and how to make a difference.
And I've had moments of thinking
about leaving the force.
I finally had a realization that this
gives me an opportunity to have a
different angle as a white woman and
also as a police officer to potentially
make a difference even if it's
just with changing myself.
I didn't hesitate.
I've been a civilian my entire life
and I consider it an honor to have an
opportunity to provide
voice for law enforcement.
And the men and women that
serve our communities.
I think it's fundamentally important for
society to respect law enforcement men
and women that serve our communities
with tremendous honor and distinction end
up getting a bad rap.
I think that that's very harmful.
I think that it is important.
I think it's imperative to speak
whenever you have an opportunity to,
and I think that all of us in whatever
movements were part of or whatever belief
systems were part of should use our gifts.
You know deescalation training is sitting
in a room like this with a PowerPoint
and walking officers' through
scenarios and nothing.
Nothing in a scenario is ever going
to be like the real world in defensive
officer's like only those of us that
walk in the shoes of having a badge and a
gun and being in these high stress
situations can really articulate what it's
like to make these split second decisions
with our training officers need to be
in these types of discussions.
Owning their shit and being like,
I did this wrong and I have this prejudice
and how can I sit with people who can
teach me and change me?
This is what I think is sort of
dangerous about a conversation like this.
Is that really the only thing that I
want law enforcement being trained on is
the law. Okay. Um,
this nebulous conversation about thinking
about how I think about things and
yeah,
some of us in law enforcement think of
ourselves as social workers with a gun.
And that's concerning because your,
your job is to enforce the law as
someone in the field who wants more
deescalation training.
It's not because I don't believe in a
lot of the laws that I enforce and it is
my job to enforce the law.
I'm not allow warning officer,
that's not what I signed up to do.
But we are given the
discretion to make choices.
And that's why we need more
training because we're human beings.
Just in my perspective,
and I appreciate your support of law
enforcement and your perspective.
Yeah. And I and I appreciate
your perspective as well as your,
your real service that you've done so and
I don't want it. We are disagreements.
Certainly don't take away from my
respect and admiration for your service.
Let's thank you for this.
We all respect the service of everyone
who works to the service of others.
I don't think anybody in this room
is against individual officers.
The conversation is to take a step back
and recognize that this institution is a
relic of Anglo policing from European
culture but also slave catching and deep
rooted racism in American policy and we
need to take that step back and re sent
to this conversation on the fact that
it's bigger than just an officer.
I think part of the problem is
that we're still so segregated.
Where do we go to have
these conversations?
Where do we go to learn from each
other to break down the stereotypes?
It's systemic and I'm so thrilled that
there's a black lives matter movement.
It's really exciting.
Guys. Thank you so much. I know
this hasn't been an easy one,
but I appreciate your time.
Feel free to continue the discussion.
If you'd like outside.
Yeah.
It's a pleasure.
I really appreciate you speaking your
truth and in here and mine as well.
I really appreciate all of you
guys. Okay? Yeah. Hey guys,
I'm Jason and I'm Dan and we just want
to say thank you once again for watching
another episode of middle ground.
As always,
let us know in the comments what you
think we want to get into these issues.
We want to be able heal divides,
Marvey all the cross boundaries,
and also let us know what you think
future episodes should be about.
Click here to subscribe to more videos.
Click here to watch more videos
and we will.